[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know if you've seen the show
barry it's now in season three on hbo
max and sunday nights you can see a new
episode 10 eastern bill hader we spoke
with bill a couple of days ago
talking about this and it's a really
dark comedy
um
it feels like they write themselves into
corners just like you had uh with
breaking bad so you have a hitman
who doesn't want to be a hit man anymore
he wants to be an actor
but he's still a hit man while he's
trying to become an actor
and somehow they make it they make it
work it's a wonderful show and uh i
started off the interview with bill
hader where we had fritzi's
impersonation of the voice on saturday
night live
don pardo
see the problem you know when i said
that you're going to be on and then
fritzy
who doesn't he does his don pardo
you know saturday night live thing so
it's i'll say uh bill hader joining us
and then he doesn't say yes he'll go
with guest host bill hader musical guest
lizzo
ladies and gentlemen bill
hater
how would you judge that bill
that was pretty good
i had to do it i did pardo one time was
uh sick and i had to do it and i had to
do a pardo impression
but i did like 1970s pardo
how did it sound
it was terrible i was like
it's saturday night live
you did sound a little keith morrison
like with oh yeah keith morrison yeah
yeah that it never fails
oh yeah keith morrison's now my now has
become a thing there was one where a guy
was talking about uh it was like his dad
tried to bury him alive or something
like it was something awful
and keith morrison
was kind of like
saying your dad tried to buck
your dad tried to bury you alive
that must have been wild
he didn't say that but the whole kind of
yeah tone of it was like he was like
what a weird world we live in
it's still nothing trumps
that pesky dna and then we had keith
morrison on he goes
i never said that i i know yeah i don't
think he
you know john mullaney said he saw that
and then i said it to keith morrison and
keith morrison was very polite but the
look on his face was i've never said
that and then i had oh maybe he never
did say that and i just was relayed to
me by john so
regardless it's really funny what role
does narcissism play in barry
well i mean it's about hollywood
[Laughter]
it's about actors
i don't know if it could get
yeah i mean narcissism plays a massive
part of it and also i mean
people always go like oh barry's this
new soul and everything and i'm like
he's
you know if you want to be an actor
yeah you're a narcissist you know he's
always out for
himself and even you know being a people
pleaser like he is that's its own form
of narcissism i need people to like me i
need people to appreciate me
is narcissistic in a way so you know it
it kind of comes in all its different
forms in the show
do you know how this ends
no we take it see my scene
we really do take it scene by scene and
it's really nerve-racking because when
people like it it's like oh good well i
don't know if you're gonna like because
i don't know what's gonna happen so
i mean i'm gonna get off the this with
you and then duffy boudreau is one of
our writers my best friend i grew up was
in tulsa he's going to come over and
we're going to sit here and just go all
right so here's the next scene
and then we call alec berg we call liz
sarnoff another writer and we just go is
this making sense you know
it feels like and i i go back to
breaking bad that breaking bad it felt
like they would write themselves into a
corner and you'd say how are they
getting out
and i don't know if you followed that
same template that we're going to write
ourselves into a corner
and we're going to figure out how we get
out of this that's believable
yeah well so much of it you know
breaking bad obviously had a big
influence on especially the pilot of
barry and that kind of inception of
barry and then it was kind of like
as we the show went on it was like oh
let's you know
you know it became a little different
kind of more of like a weirder character
piece at a time but uh
but um but yeah we i think when you
follow what the character would do
and you're just following it step by
step and what is interesting
you go well we got to make the bold
choice and the bold choice usually
leaves you in a corner you know when
you're watching this
series i couldn't help but think what do
your friends think
or your significant other that you have
these thoughts in your mind to be able
to create something like this bill
i don't know i mean it's funny i talked
to my sisters and my dad in oklahoma and
they're always like yeah no that's
totally you
[Laughter]
you know my sister's like you know
you're always in your room watching
movies and
reading and it's like yeah you're like
the
you know
uh
nice guy and then they see the stuff and
there's like oh there's like a real
darkness and weirdness there and it's
like yeah i don't know yeah it comes out
that way
he's uh bill hader he is the star of
barry back for season three there's
sundays on hbo at 10 also available to
stream on hbo max were you class clown
in high school yeah i was i was actually
voted the class clown in high school
yep can't really do anything with that i
was class clown in my high school as
well really yeah you did something with
it you got on espn and all this stuff i
don't think i got on because i was a
class clown oh they thought you were
funny
you came on you're like i was a class
clown and they said do you think you got
saturday night live because you're 100
you go anymore is that on your resume
lauren's like um you know everyone from
chevy to ellen playcore
[Laughter]
we're the class clown you don't get on
unless you and you have to bring your
yearbook in and he's like
very well did you ever imitate lorne
michael's two lauren michaels
uh
[Laughter]
i don't think so i remember i did it
once on seth meyers and i kind of
stepped it was like oh i made fun of dad
you know
and seth went don't worry he doesn't
watch the show
and how do you guys not crack up on the
set like what what helps you not crack
up when you're doing barry i'm bad i
mean you i mean it's well known i'm a
soft touch i break at the i mean henry
winkler and anthony kerrigan and
sarah goldberg and and steven root just
make me laugh i can't i think there's a
blooper reel they just like released and
it's like yeah i can't keep it together
yeah i saw that
fallon was always terrible on saturday
live he couldn't hold it together
no
yeah yeah he and horatio would get each
other laughing i asked lauren about it
once i would do like stefan's and every
single one i would laugh at and then i
told lauren i'm really sorry about this
is getting ridiculous and he was like
well if what you were saying wasn't
funny it would be an issue but what
you're saying is really funny so
how often do you have to remind yourself
that this is a comedy
um
we don't we kind of
don't we don't it's weird it's like i
don't think of it in terms of anything
genre either way so it's kind of the
story dictates it
where it goes and sometimes
it's really funny and then
on some instinctual
way you just kind of go
oh this would probably turn dark here
you know and you just you know you try
it out it's very weirdly instinctual
the success of this sometimes brings out
friends or friends you didn't know you
had that may want to be
in berry
how do you deal with that when somebody
says hey
i would love to be in barry
um
i you know if it makes sense you know i
don't know i i'm very open to a lot of
things like i just asked if i could be
in berry without asking if i could barry
oh you want to be in barry you can be
married
okay
all right so all
right
you can be embarrassed okay what would
you like for me to play
what do you want to play
uh i don't want to do a corpse
okay
but
maybe one or two lines would be nice
is that i mean i'm in screen actors
guild and obviously i'm in all right
yeah you can you can come be on barry
i'm not serious well yeah you can be
embarrassed
okay you think i'm joking i'm not you
can come yeah we'll figure it out if it
works with your schedule well i'm not
joking so i'm hoping you're not joking
no i'm not joking this is not joking
so when season four comes out we can
replay this clip yeah
and i will say you weren't joking and
then you'll say you weren't joking
either
and it's like
that was genius yes it was
okay all right i like that you're in all
right but only you none of those other
like you're far back to work with you
i don't want any of those jerks were in
the studio in the show
i'm sorry guys uh
bill you know what the craft services
these guys could be craft services i
don't want them on the set oh you don't
want to watch them
[Laughter]
uh well good luck with this as i i would
email bill i'd say any updates on on
barry and they'd say no working on it
and then finally i saw her it was coming
out i said don't don't get up so i know
that's my i love those emails hey don't
pick this up we're all counting on you
yeah my buddy sends me uh
uh leslie nielsen an airplane when he
opens the copies like good luck we're
all counting
good luck we're all kind of you
know all right well let me know about
season four yeah you're gonna be in it
now all right well we'll figure it out
dan thank you buddy good to talk to you
again thank you pal
that's bill hader and i guess i talked
my way into season four of berry